in this video we'll talk about the
morphogenetic movements that are
happening during the process of
gastrulation
so here are few key points regarding
gastrulation gastrulation is all about
coordinated movement of many cells and
this movement happen throughout the
embryo patterns of gastrulation vary
throughout the animal kingdom and there
are several type of core movement that
can happen during gastrulation in this
video we are going to talk about that
so the possible movements that can occur
during gastrulation phase are
invagination involution ingression
delamination and epiboly these five type
of movement are the basic ABCDs of the
gastrul gastrulation or morphogenetic
movements so in this video we are going
to break down on each of these movement
and try to appreciate when they occur
and how they occur
so before that let me tell you that
Louis walpert mentioned once that it's
not birth marriage or death but
gastrulation is the most fascinating
part of the life
so why
gastrulation is so important and what
really happens during gastrulation
so let me tell you briefly that during
gastrulation a cell in the blastula can
move their positions and they can obtain
new neighbors and can move in a
coordinated fashion so it's a pretty
complicated kind of phenomena
so the first type of gastrulation
movement that we are going to look at is
invagination as the name suggests there
is something invaginating right so
invagination simply means in foldings of
a sheet of cells just like this
animation you can see the yellow cells
are invaginating inwards
just like you are touching a rubber ball
and there is a depression when it when
you're poking it this movement is
exactly similar to that
so this kind of movement happens during
sea arching endoderm formation
so also this kind of movement can be
found in amphioxious
so when the amphioxious blastula is
giving rise to the gastrula the
endoderm region in vaginates inside and
eventually forms the arkentiron
so this is one of the another example
The Next Movement is known as involution
involution is the inward movement of an
expanding outer layer so that the new
layer is now spread internal to the
external cell layer okay if you don't
understand follow this particular yellow
cells
these yellow cells are actually
generated from these green cells which
are on the outer side
when the outer side that means these
green cells are dividing and increasing
in number it is move it is moving slowly
slowly inwards just like these arrows
and it is spreading just beneath these
outer layer
and this kind of movement is known as
involution
just for better understanding let's look
at this process with the help of
animation
so you can see how these yellow cells
are
involuting inside the green outer layer
Next Movement is ingression ingression
is a process by which individual cells
move out from the surface into the
interior of the embryo but before moving
out of the layer it is it has to perform
epithelial to mesenchymal transition if
you don't know what is epithelial to
mesenchymal transition I have a video on
that
so here you can see this yellow cell
become mesenchymal and moving out from
the layer of these green cells and this
kind of movement is known as ingression
let me tell you ingression is found in
case of a vertebrate especially human
embryonic development where the cells of
the epiblast Ingress and move inside the
Primitive streak and then move down and
move away from the Primitive streak in a
cross section you can see this so look
at that particular dot in the cross
section view this cell is in racing that
means first it has undergone EMT or
epithelial to mesenchymal transition so
it became loose and now it is moving
towards the Primitive streak now it's
going down towards the Primitive streak
and now it's moving away from the
Primitive streak and it would become
something else in the new location
now similar kind of movement or
ingression kind of movement can be found
during the CR chin mesoderm development
here you can see the red represents the
misoderm and the mesodermal cells are
ingressing inside the embryo
the next kind of movement is
delamination delamination is very
similar to ingression but delamination
results in splitting of one cellular
sheet into a parallel sheet
now one difference between delamination
and ingression is delamination occurs in
a collective fashion one cell doesn't
move inside it's a whole layer of cells
that splits or move inside
so delamination is very important type
of morphogenetic movement
and then epiboly is the last movement
that we are going to talk about
epiboli is one kind of movement where
epithelial sheets are spreading as a
unit so it's again
the movement
and it encloses the deeper layers of the
embryo in this case you can see the
yellow sheet is kind of like
engulfing the green sheet of cells
so this is known as epiboli epiboli can
occur by cell division cell shape
changes and several layers of cells that
that are interconnected and they can
like split into smaller layers
now this kind of movement is very common
in case of
frog embryonic development so in case of
frogs you can see the ectoderm endoderm
and mesoderm are labeled in three
different colors now if you follow the
arrows you can see how this red ectoderm
is slowly slowly engulfing the entire
endoderm
and this is what happens during ectoderm
formation in amphibians and this is an
example of epipoli so I hope this video
was informative and short enough in a
different video we would talk about each
of these movements and try to understand
the molecular mechanisms that is
governing this kind of coordinated
movement
please visit my Facebook and Instagram
page for more flashcards and notes you
can support our Channel using super
thanks see you in next video